rohstoffabbau im weltall auf 8 dieses
jahr ist es schon soweit die vorarbeiten
beginnen die amerikanische firma
teamspace industries wird ihre erste
test mission starten und einem kleinen
satelliten mit dem namen von spectre ich
ins weltall bringer fiel der firma ist
es auch aktiven zu landen und deren
rohstoffe abzubauen
ist das der beginn einer völlig neuen
industriezweig
herzlich willkommen beim zweiten wechsel
es klingt wie science-fiction
doch das private unternehmen die
pelzindustrie schon 2020 ein erstes
autonomes raum fahrzeug auf einem
aktuellen lang geht um dort nach wasser
zu suchen und diese später auch
abzubauen und sich auf diese mission
vorzubereiten soll noch dieses jahr ein
erster testlauf in der erdumlaufbahn
erfolgen der satellit spector ist mit
zwei kameras mit denen er die oberfläche
eines aktiven abscannen kann
die daten werden dann zurück zur erde
gesendet wo experten entscheiden auf
welchem aktuellen 2020 gelandet werden
dann außerdem an bord ist das eigens
entworfene antriebssystem der firma das
komplett auf wasser basiert und das ist
auch wichtig denn der erste rohstoff der
deep space industrie von atto ide
abbauen will ist nicht etwa gold oder
diamanten wie auch vielen aktiven ja
vermutet wird wenn man ganz normales
wasser wasser ist nämlich mit seinen
bestandteilen sauerstoff und wasserstoff
ein hervorragender preisstopp und
vielleicht darf benzin des weltalls 90
prozent des gewichts einer rakete ist ja
nur der treibstoff denn je mehr ladung
man ins all bringen möchte desto mehr
treibstoff braucht man auch und
treibstoff selbst wiegt wieder eine
menge und deswegen braucht man auch
dafür wie der treibstoff und so weiter
und so fort wenn man jetzt nur so viel
treibstoff mitnehmen würde dass man
gerade zu einem aktiven kommt kann man
dort mit hilfe von deep space industries
auftanken und von da aus weiter zum mars
oder flur noch weiter entfernten
planeten und sonnensystemen fliegen eine
tankstelle im all das könnte der beginn
einer völlig neuen branche sein in der
man milliarden verdienen kann wenn das
so alles klappt wenn ihr mehr über
firmen erfahren wollt die im weltall
rohstoffe
bauen wollen dann klickt auf dieses
video von doktor watson sehr spannend
und hier oben da könnte er den kanal
abonnieren und sagt mir was meint ihr
dazu wird ab juli farming einmal so
normal wie trekking oder kohleabbau
diskutiert mit mir in den kommentaren
ansonsten bekannt